(Ich bin Salar Patrick Bahrampoori,
und das ist meine Geschichte.)
(40 Jahre nach der Flucht meiner
Familie will ich zurück in den Iran.)
(Zusammen mit meinem Freund
Reto Wettstein.)
(Wir fahren den gleichen Weg
wie auf der Flucht 1980,
in umgekehrter Richtung.)
(Wir haben uns zwei Jahre vorberei-
tet, sind durch acht Länder gefahren,
fast 5'000 km,
bis zur iranischen Grenze,
um herauszufinden,
wer ich bin und woher ich komme.)
(Als 1980 der Erste Golfkrieg
ausbrach, war ich eineinhalbjährig.)
(Unter Beschuss mussten meine Eltern
mit mir und meinem Bruder
unser Zuhause in Teheran verlassen.)
(Wir flohen in die Schweiz
und fingen ein neues Leben an.)
(Ich bin in Chur aufgewachsen
und habe das KV gemacht.)
(Als ich 22 war, starb mein Vater.)
So, jetzt gehen wir.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Wir sind im Iran, wir sind im Iran.
(Mit 39 bin ich an einem Punkt,
an dem ich mehr wissen muss.)
(Das kann ich nur, wenn ich
von ganz vorne anfange, im Iran.)
(Ein Abenteuer:
Weil uns Papiere fehlen,
wird unser Auto an der
iranischen Grenze beschlagnahmt.)
(Es ist das erste Mal seit dem Tod
meines Vaters, dass ich im Iran bin,
in meinem Vaterland.)
(Statt mit unserem Auto
geht es mit dem Taxi weiter.)
Wir haben viel Stutz liegen gelassen,
haben kein Auto mehr.
Wir sind im Iran.
Ich bin gerade etwas durch den Wind.
Gurtpflicht haben sie auch da.
* Hupen *
Schau, der Motor liegt dort unten.
* Orientalische Streichmusik *
* Orientalische Saitenmusik *
(Wir fahren nach Teheran -
zu meiner Instagram-Freundin Samira.)
(Für unsere Weiterfahrt
bietet sie uns ihr Auto an.)
(Samira empfängt uns
mit ihrem Mann Yusouf
zu einem iranischen Frühstück.)
* Heitere Musik *
Mir wird halb schlecht.
* Meckern *
Das ist das Maul.
- Nein!
That's great.
- What you want.
Even if the Kebab smells too much,
I can't.
My God!
Ich weiss nicht, wie ich danken soll.
Wir fahren mit ihrem Auto weiter.
Sie hat uns vorher schon geholfen,
mit allen Papieren und allem.
* Sie sprechen Farsi. *
* Orientalische Musik mit Gesang *
Der Verkehr, schau das mal an!
Jetzt bin ich froh, sind wir wieder
selber unterwegs und können fahren.
V.a. da,
auf der Spurensuche meiner Familie.
(Wir sind unterwegs in eine
der eindrücklichsten Städte der Welt:
Isfahan.)
(In dieser Stadt wollte mein Vater
unserer Familie
die persische Kultur näherbringen,
in den Sommerferien,
als ich 14-jährig war.)
(Ich erinnere mich, wie glücklich
mein Vater in seiner Heimat war.)
Es tut richtig gut, jetzt da zu sein.
* Intensive Streichmusik *
(In Isfahan treffen wir
eine Freundin von Samira - Samin.)
Ich glaube, da ist sie.
Schau mal, das könnte sie sein!
(Sie zeigt uns
die Schönheit ihrer Stadt -
und die Universität,
in der mein Vater unterrichtet hat.)
* Sie sprechen Farsi und Englisch. *
Auf Wiedersehen!
(Hier in Isfahan
erkenne ich den Iran wieder,
der meine Heimat
hätte werden sollen.)
(Ein Iran, der mit dem Bild der west-
lichen Medien so wenig zu tun hat.)
Royal Wedding!
- (Aber welches ist das wahre Bild?)
(Was sind Erinnerungen wert,
die sich im Nichts auflösen,
wie das siebenfache Echo
in dieser Moschee?)
* Verhallendes Echo *
* Entspannte Saitenmusik *
Ich habe als Kind
immer Karottensaft getrunken.
In der Schweiz ist er fast uner-
schwinglich, man findet ihn fast nie.
Darum siehst du so gut.
Darum sehe ich so gut und
habe eine Brille, seit ich zehn bin.
Das ist für mich das Grösste.
Ich könnte den ganzen Tag
Karottensaft trinken.
Das sollte ich öfter tun.
Das ist im Iran ein normales Getränk.
"Zum Wohl" heisst "Salamati".
Hoppla, schon reingelaufen.
Es gibt so viele Regeln in dem Land.
Ich kenne nicht alle.
Er hat schon komisch geschaut.
- Ja, warum?
"Salamati" sagst du
zum Anstossen mit Alkohol,
das ist ja hier nicht so ... Aber
eben, ich kenne nicht alle Regeln.
(Wir sind auf Spurensuche
meines Vaters.)
Mein Vater hat an dieser Universität
1970/71 zwei Jahre
Sportwissenschaften unterrichtet.
Er hat Sportlehrer ausgebildet.
Es fährt mir schon ein,
wie er hier reingefahren sein muss.
Ich weiss einfach, mit wie viel Liebe
und Passion er das gemacht hat.
Der Sport war wirklich sein Leben.
Irgendwie habe ich das
vielleicht auch von ihm.
Mir geht es ja gleich.
Ja, es freut mich sehr,
dass ich das mal sehen kann.
Das tut gut.
Schön, ich war hier. Ich freue mich,
das meinem Bruder zu schicken.
Und Mama!
* Orientalische Popmusik *
* Samin singt mit. *
Ich war als Kind hier
und habe mir vorgestellt,
dass da ein tiefer Fluss ist.
Jetzt sieht man:
Der ist weder tief noch sonst was.
Es sind einfach die 33 wunderschönen
Pfeiler, darum heisst es Si-o-se Pol.
Wir spazierten hier, tranken Tee
in den Teehäuschen unter der Brücke.
Heute hat der Fluss kein Wasser mehr.
Das wollte ich anschauen.
Jetzt kann man auf dem Grund
des Flusses gehen, das ist schade.
Allerdings gehe es noch zwei, drei
Tage, dann komme wieder Wasser.
Es kommt und geht,
wird irgendwo gestaut.
Aber sie haben Wassernotstand
hier im Iran,
und es ist kein schönes Bild.
(Wir haben uns
von Samin verabschiedet
und fahren nach Gharghab.)
* Fröhliche Musik *
(In Gharghab wohnen der Cousin
meines Vaters und dessen Frau.)
(Beide habe ich
25 Jahre nicht mehr gesehen.)
Wo sind wir hier?
- Keine Ahnung.
Irgendwo im Nirgendwo,
und das heisst:
Behest.
Sind wir?
Behest heisst Paradies, glaube ich.
* Klagende Streichmusik *
* Düstere orientalische Musik *
Da siehst du: Da ist nichts.
Hier gibt es keine Uhr.
Hier wird es mal hell und mal dunkel.
Jetzt weiss ich,
warum das nicht auf der Karte ist.
Ist es nicht auf der Karte?
- Nein, ich habe es nicht gefunden.
Da ist ein Schwimmbad.
Ja, das war einmal alles sehr schön,
das ist jetzt recht runtergekommen.
* Hundebellen *
* Knurren *
Salam!
(Mit der Iranischen Revolution wurde
das Ackerland an Bauern verteilt.)
(Meinen Verwandten
blieb ein Leben hinter Mauern.)
* Bellen *
Ah, that's Vali-Khan?
Vali-Khan.
Oh, good man.
- Yes.
Das sind sie und ihr Mann,
hier, wo wir jetzt sind.
Mein Vater.
Mit dem Anzug. Das ist mein Vater.
Baba.
Lustig, ich habe meinen Vater
noch nie so jung gesehen.
* Klagende Streichmusik *
(Wir fahren 30 km weit
zum ehemaligen Familienlandsitz.)
(Dort verbrachte mein Vater
in der Jugend glückliche Zeiten.)
* Sphärische orientalische Klänge *
(Von hier
stammt meine letzte Erinnerung
zusammen mit meinem Vater im Iran.)
Das ist alles von unserer Familie,
das ist alles Bahrampoori.
Die Brücke ...
Das ist es, ich habe es so im Kopf.
Du hast doch das Bild auch gesehen.
Ja, ich habe es auch so im Kopf.
Seit der Familie das abhanden
gekommen ist durch die Landesreform,
ist er nicht mehr hierhergekommen,
40 Jahre.
Ich war mit 14 mit meinem Vater hier.
Da hatte es noch viel mehr ...
Wir waren dort vorne,
das war alles in Betrieb.
Wir haben hier noch ...
Da hatte es Wasser.
Da war ich als Kind in den Ferien,
da haben wir noch irgendwo gehaust,
in so einem Haus.
* Sie sprechen Farsi. *
Sein Grossvater
wurde da drin erschossen
von irgendwelchen Räubern.
Wie das in 25 Jahren
kaputtgegangen ist ...
Da lebten noch Leute drin.
Wahnsinn.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
dass diese Zeit
mit deiner Familie zusammenhängt?
Schon krass, oder?
Es ist einfach
eine wahnsinnige Familiengeschichte.
Es war eine grosse Familie,
sie waren Grossgrundbesitzer.
Wenn man heute sieht, was aus allem
geworden ist, ist es schon ...
Es tut einem weh.
* Klagende Flötenmusik *
Hey, das ist ja ...
Wenn sie es schon weggenommen haben,
hätten sie es pflegen sollen.
Man hätte es aufrechterhalten können,
aber einfach so vergammeln lassen,
tut einfach weh.
* Klagende orientalische Klänge *
Es war das Ziel der Reise,
wirklich da zu sein,
eines der ganz grossen Ziele,
ein Hauptziel.
Und jetzt sind wir hier.
Aber für mich ist hier der letzte ...
... iranische Kontaktpunkt
mit meinem Vater.
Deshalb ist es schön, hier zu sein.
Leider ohne ihn.
Auch das ist das Leben,
die Vergänglichkeit.
Das war etwas, das für mich
wohl nie abgeschlossen ist,
weil es mich mit dem Iran
und meinem Vater verbindet.
* Melancholische Flötenmusik *
(Mein Vater und sein Cousin ver-
brachten ihre Kindheit in Mahallat.)
(Wir fahren in die Strassen
ihrer Vergangenheit.)
In diesem Quartier waren sie daheim,
sind aufgewachsen und haben gelebt.
Das sind wirklich Erinnerungen
von mir, all diese Gerüche.
Das Ghormeh Sabzi,
das ist Minze, ganze Säcke voll.
(Und dann merken wir,
dass wir beobachtet werden.)
Kannst du mal die Kamera ausschalten?
Ich weiss nicht,
wohin die jetzt verschwunden sind.
Plötzlich waren sie weg.
- Ja.
Wie auch er.
- Er ist da im Auto.
Er verfolgt uns.
Mir ist der Hunger leicht verflogen.
Wir wurden gerade das erste Mal
kontrolliert, völlig okay,
aber mir ist es
ein bisschen eingefahren.
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Freiheit.)
(Tun und lassen zu können,
was man will,
zu reisen, wie man will.)
(Für mich vielleicht
die wichtigste Erfahrung:
wie grossartig Freiheit ist.)
(Und wie hart es sein muss,
wenn man sie nicht hat.)
(Samira ruft an und erzählt,
dass all unsere Kontaktpersonen
befragt wurden.)
(Sie bürgt für uns.)
(Aber jetzt fühlen wir uns bedroht.)
* Salar spricht Farsi. *
I call you later.
Bye-bye.
Hey!
Sie sagte:
Hätten wir den Brief nicht gehabt,
wären wir jetzt
in Golpayegan in der Kiste.
Und auch nicht so schnell
rausgekommen.
Sie wollten die ganze Story hören.
Sie glaubt, damit ist es beendet.
Aber sie würde uns raten,
jetzt Richtung Teheran zu fahren.
Machen wir. Gehen wir!
Ja, wir müssen.
Machen wir uns auf den Weg!
* Düstere Klänge *
Es war sehr schön
hier bei der Familie.
Vom Herz und der Familie her
war das das Schönste und Beste.
Ich glaube,
mein Vater wäre mega glücklich,
dass ich die Reise mache. Und stolz.
Stolz
ist vielleicht das falsche Wort.
Ich glaube, er wäre einfach froh,
denn er wollte uns
diese Kultur immer mitgeben.
Ich merke, dass ich dem
zu viel Zeit gelassen habe.
Aber es ist, wie es ist.
Es ist nie zu spät.
Aber es ist gut,
dass ich es jetzt mache.
* Düstere Klänge *
(Zurück in Teheran.)
(Unsere Reise fühlt sich anders an,
seit wir kontrolliert wurden.)
(Das schlechte Gefühl bleibt -
aus gutem Grund.)
Das ist die Polizei.
Was will jetzt der wieder von uns,
mein Gott?
Was soll ich hier?
Hier stehen bleiben oder was?
Hey!
Jetzt ist plötzlich gut.
Ja, aber ich kann jetzt
wirklich nicht mehr. Fuck!
Wirklich, ich mag nicht mehr.
- Fahr einfach!
Ich kriege es langsam mit den Nerven.
Kannst du auch nicht mehr?
Nein, ich kann auch nicht mehr.
Ich habe gefragt:
"Wer hat gesagt, dass wir filmen?"
Er konnte es mir nicht sagen.
Wir seien gemeldet worden,
er müsse der Sache nachgehen.
Jetzt ist alles okay.
Meine Nerven sind jetzt wirklich ...
* Hupen *
... am Anschlag.
Mir vergeht momentan mega die Lust,
hier überhaupt noch etwas zu machen.
Überall muss man sich rechtfertigen.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit das Gefühl,
ich mache etwas Illegales, grässlich.
* Hupen *
Es reicht jetzt wirklich.
Ich will nur noch in die Berge
und fertig.
Und einfach nach Hause,
einfach nach Hause.
Wenn ich könnte, würde ich heute
in den Flieger steigen und gehen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Der Roadtrip geht weiter -
mit einem Geschenk des Himmels:
Taxifahrer Akhbar.)
Er sagt,
Gott habe so Leute wie uns sehr gern.
Respekt ist sehr wichtig
in dieser Kultur.
Es ist Wahnsinn:
Jeder hilft dem anderen,
zeigt ihm den Weg
und sagt ihm: "Ich bin dein Engel",
"Ich bin der Schmutz
unter deiner Fusssohle",
"Du bist mein Herz", "Sei mein Gast",
"Ich möchte dein Sklave sein".
Das sind alles Höflichkeitsformen
in einer wahnsinnig blumigen,
schönen Sprache, mit grossem Respekt.
So wie ich gestern ausgerastet bin,
das ist höchst - höchst! -
unanständig.
Das kann man nicht machen,
das passiert ihnen nicht.
Mir ist auch das Haus wichtig,
in dem meine Eltern gelebt haben,
bevor wir gegangen sind,
den Iran verlassen haben.
Ich habe ihm die Adresse gezeigt,
meine Mama hat sie aufgeschrieben.
Er weiss, wo es ist,
es sei nicht weit weg.
Ich hoffe, dass wir noch
dorthin kommen. Inshallah!
* Orientalische Streichmusik *
Wie ein Esel ist der da rausgefahren.
Das ist der Moment, in dem du
mit dem Leben abgeschlossen hast:
Du kaufst einen Töff in Teheran,
wirklich.
Ich bin wirklich schon
viel gereist in meinem Leben,
aber so ein Chaos
habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Aber es ist unglaublich,
wie ruhig die Leute bleiben.
Das ist hier einfach Alltag.
* Entspannte Folk-Musik:
"Line of Fire" von Junip *
# What would you do
if it all came back to you?
# Each crest of each wave
bright as lightning.
# What would you say
if you had to leave today?
Je länger ich hier bin,
desto mehr kann ich verstehen.
Und sehe,
wie schwierig das gewesen sein muss,
den schönen Ort zu verlassen,
doch nicht im Krieg leben zu wollen
mit den Kindern.
Durch Mami, das Studium des Vaters
und seine Arbeit in der Schweiz
hatten wir die Möglichkeit zu gehen.
Ich bin meinen Eltern sehr dankbar,
dass ich diese Möglichkeit hatte.
Und dass der persische Teil in mir
doch da ist und wachsen konnte.
Er ist in mir
und jetzt wecke ich ihn wieder.
Ich sehe: Ein Stück weit bin ich es,
aber nicht ganz.
Am Schluss
bin ich wohl wirklich ein Mix.
* Friedliche orientalische Klänge *
Er will einfach ...
Das ist so persisch.
Er will uns einfach
eine gute Zeit bereiten.
Darum geht es ihm heute.
Es ist sekundär, was wir ...
Wir kommen noch zu den Orten,
an die wir wollen.
Das ist einfach sehr persisch.
Da ist so viel Güte und Liebe.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Man muss es selbst erlebt haben.
Ich muss wohl nachher eine Zigarette
mit ihm rauchen, das ist ihm wichtig.
Ich weiss nicht, was ich sagen soll,
wenn man etwas wirklich will,
wie man das durchsetzt.
Das habe ich noch nicht verstanden.
* Sie sprechen Farsi. *
So eine kleine Zigarette.
- Reza.
"Reza", du musst auch eins nehmen.
Das hat mit Anstand zu tun.
Ich rauche eigentlich nicht.
Aber jetzt machen wir das.
* Reto lacht. *
Er würde mir das übel nehmen.
Würde ich nicht rauchen,
würde er das nicht verstehen.
Deshalb mache ich es.
Aber ich merke es schon im Kopf.
Wenn man es nicht gewohnt ist,
ist schon noch starker Tabak.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Wir sind ja auf der Spurensuche
meiner Familie.
Ich möchte sehen, wo wir
das Ende gefunden haben im Iran.
Denn es war Krieg zu dieser Zeit.
Dann die Entscheidung meiner Eltern:
"Jetzt ist es zu gefährlich,
wir gehen."
Und mir ist auf dieser Reise wichtig,
diesen Punkt zu sehen.
Aha! das hat meine Mama gesagt,
da geht es nach hinten.
Es ist eine Einbahnstrasse.
Das hinterste Haus
muss das Haus gewesen sein.
Vielleicht ist es das.
Sie hat gesagt:
Sackgasse, das hinterste Haus.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es abgerissen wurde.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Jedenfalls ist es hier.
Das hinterste Haus, was heisst das?
* Eindringliche Klaviermusik *
Ich stelle mir nur vor, wie das ist,
wenn da Bomben einschlagen,
wenn Krieg ist, du hast zwei
kleine Kinder, eineinhalb und drei.
Du packst deine Sachen.
Das einzige Geld, das sie
mitgenommen haben, war im Buggy.
Sie haben die Noten
in die Röhren gerollt.
Sie sind gegangen, haben ihre ganze
Existenz stehen und liegen lassen.
Das kann sich niemand vorstellen,
der es nicht erlebt hat, inkl. ich.
Daher kommt auch diese Wut in mir,
wenn ich Leute bei uns höre,
die sagen, da kommen
irgendwelche Leute aus dem Ausland.
Die kommen nicht aus Spass.
Was für eine Arroganz muss
in einem sein, wenn man so denkt?
Man verlässt sein Land nirgends
einfach zum Spass.
Meine Eltern sagen nicht:
"Wir sind geflüchtet."
Sie wollten keine Flüchtlinge sein.
Aber schlussendlich
war es eine Flucht.
Das ist happig.
Das Leben,
das ich in der Schweiz führen darf,
in einem der besten Länder der Welt,
mit allen Möglichkeiten ...
Was soll man da sagen?
Klar ist das besser
und klar schätze ich das.
Und es wird mir auf diesem Trip
recht bewusst. Ja.
Hier würde jetzt vielleicht
unser Name stehen,
wenn wir geblieben wären.
Das wäre auch ein Leben gewesen.
Es ist irgendwie schön zu sehen,
wo meine Eltern waren.
Es ist ein ruhiger Ort.
Ja, hier hat mein Schweizer Leben
angefangen, ja.
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Darband Sar,
70 km von Teheran entfernt.)
(Samira und ihr Mann Yusouf
haben uns mit Kollegen
in ihre Ferienwohnung eingeladen.)
(Es ist unser letzter Tag im Iran.)
Wir haben es fast geschafft.
- Wir haben es fast geschafft.
Ich kann fast nicht mehr.
Ich habe geschwollene Augen.
So wenig habe ich geschlafen.
* Entspannte Rockmusik,
lautes Gähnen *
* Sie sprechen Englisch. *
Ich geniesse es noch,
bald geht es nach Hause.
Dann gibt es das nicht mehr so.
* Rockiger Indie-Song:
"Villain" von Junip *
Endlich Ski fahren im Iran,
darauf habe ich lange Jahre gewartet.
# Never mind what kept you going now.
# Never mind, never mind.
Jetzt ist es gut, wir sind da.
Mich freut es, in den Bergen zu sein.
Hier fühle ich mich zu Hause.
Wäre ich im Iran aufgewachsen,
wäre ich hier in der Hocke
und nicht auf der Corviglia,
in Laax oder Zermatt auf einem Berg.
Dann wäre ich halt hier
und würde wohl dasselbe machen.
Es macht richtig Spass heute.
* Sanfte orientalische Klänge *
Ich habe ja gedacht,
ich finde hier Antworten,
glaube aber,
dass es mich eher aufgewühlt hat.
Es hat mir auch Antworten gegeben,
klare Antworten,
aber es ist jetzt nicht fertig.
Es war mir wichtig,
die Spuren meines Vaters zu finden.
Das habe ich in meinem Leben
ehrlich gesagt verdrängt.
Jetzt habe ich gemerkt,
dass es mich viel mehr berührt,
als ich all die Jahre
gedacht oder zugelassen habe.
Willst du den Brief an deinen Vater
noch lesen oder nicht?
Ich glaube, es würde mich jetzt
sehr mitnehmen, weisst du.
Aber es wäre eigentlich gut für mich,
um es abzuschliessen.
(Einen Monat
vor dem Tod meines Vaters -
er war knapp 61, ich 22 -
schrieb ich ihm einen Brief.)
(Einen Abschiedsbrief.)
(Seither habe ich es
nicht mehr geschafft, ihn zu lesen.)
(Ich habe ihn aber
auf diese Reise mitgenommen.)
* Entspannte Folk-Musik:
"Line of Fire" von Junip *
# If put to the test,
# would you step back
from the line of fire?
# Hold everything back,
all emotion set aside it.
# Takes you as you fall,
no one else around you.
# No one to understand you,
no one to hear your calls.
# Look through all your dark corners.
# You're backed up against the wall.
# Step back from the line of fire.
Ich bin froh.
Man muss sich den Sachen stellen.
Es ist einfach so im Leben,
egal bei was, bei allem.
Jetzt haben wir das gemacht
auf dieser Reise von A bis Z.
Ich habe mich nichts entzogen.
Der Brief
war für mich das Schwierigste,
das wollte ich bis zum Schluss nicht.
Weil ich wusste,
dass es verdammt wehtut.
Jetzt ist alles gemacht -
jetzt kann man nach Hause.